I think the government's not a great job
I think the better government working
with state and local has really done a
terrific job now the keys are in we've
just got word on the keys that was just
wiped out that got it was a hurricane
drivin it but we're getting in
tremendous amounts of supplies and
medical and a lot of other things after
the keys but most for the most part the
electric is going back on it's already
on it certifications like by a B but
it's going back on on a daily basis we
have masses massive amounts of
electricians massive amounts of
electrical workers all over the state
they came from all over the country and
came from Canada's as far away as Canada
there's never been a globalization of
electrical workers like we have in the
state of Florida and it's going on very
rapidly much of it is already on
I'll be going to the Virgin Islands this
next week as you know is United Nations
and I'm going to be going to the murder
Virgin Islands and Puerto Rico sometime
at the end of next week or the following
week I spoke to both governor's we've
got it very well covered Virgin Islands
was really hit they were hit like about
as hard as I've ever seen but the Virgin
Islands were hit but I'll be going there
at the end of the week or the beginning
of the following week I shall also be
wondering who the same makes in United
Nations the review of what about well
you'll see what I'm going to be doing
verse you are clear October but I will
say this the Iran deal is one of the
worst deals I've ever seen certainly at
a minimum the spirit of the deal is just
atrociously kept but the Iran deal is
not
is not a fair deal to this country it's
a deal that should have never ever been
made and you'll see what we're doing in
a couple of weeks is going to be it's
going to be an octo we're going to see
you're going to see what we are not
going to stand for what they're doing to
this country they have violated so many
different elements but they've also
violated the spirit of that deal and you
will see what we'll be doing in October
it will be very evident from the
Republicans
many Republicans really like it as you
know I was with a great Republican
representative just now who you know
very well and two of them and they are
very very happy with what I'm doing and
I'm a Republican through and through but
I'm also finding that sometimes to get
things through it's not working that way
and you know we got very poorly treated
on the health care plan and now you see
what's happening where people are going
single-payer exactly what I said would
happen and single payer would be a
terrible thing for our country so I am
look my relationship with the
Republicans is excellent many of them
agree with what I'm doing
you just since or to Mario you know I'm
talking about
we just met with two great Republican
representatives who love what I'm doing
but we have to get things passed and if
we can't get things passed that we have
to go a different route but we have to
get things passed now you've covered my
statement very accurately on the dinner
last night hat
you know they cannot obstruct for a
while because we definitely need a wall
I just felt by the way to the President
of Mexico and as you know it's been
impossible to reach him because of the
he was in the mountains where they had
the earthquake it was new cell we spoke
yesterday but the phone the connection
never got put together because he had no
access to cell but we just had a good
call just got finished with him had that
whole earthquake is terrible it's just
her so we paid our respect and he
likewise also paid his respects with
respect to her Mahendra
I don't know anything about it I just
heard about it I doubt he would do I've
known him a long time he is a very
straight shooter so it could be that he
is too plain that he's paying for it I
don't know anything about it I really
don't I just heard about it total
confidence I know for a long time is a
very honorable man I have confidence in
Gary
gallica bekulistan or their the question
about the way
yeah they were and we had a great
meeting Tim Scott's been a friend of
mine for a long time I've been a
supporter of his when I was a civilian I
was one of his earliest supporters and I
supported him when he ran and we had a
great talk yesterday I think especially
in light of the advent of Antipa if you
look at what's going on there you know
you have some pretty bad dudes on the
other side also and essentially that's
what I said now because of what's
happened since then with that deep you
look at you know really what's happened
since Charlottesville
a lot of people are saying in fact a lot
of people have actually written key
Trump might have a point I said you got
some very bad people on the other side
also which is true but we had a great we
had a great conversation and he also has
legislation which I actually like very
much the concept of which I support to
get people going into certain areas and
building and constructing and putting
people to work and I told him yesterday
that's a concept I could support various
do you have to make any
we did talk about that by the way is
something I do but it's something I
certainly was continued to do and we did
talk about I would I would do it I told
them I would do and he knows we've got
the main let me tell you he knows we've
already done it but I told him I told
them very strongly I like that and I
also like very much legislation having
to do with jobs in certain areas mark
short said the other day and he worked
with the Obamacare process that you can
count members
I'll give you a great example so we had
a surprise from John McCain and we had
the vote and then John McCain Kennedy
came out of nowhere and we had a
surprise it was a very unpleasant
surprise and now what are we looking at
we have people now talking about
single-payer and that's what we get so
the Republicans have to stick together
better they had the votes and then John
McCain changed his mind pure and simple
and if the Republicans don't stick
together that I'm going to have to do
more and more and by the way the
Republican Party agrees with me the
people out there definitely agree with
me if they're unable to stick together
then I'm going to have to get a little
help from the Democrats and I've got
that I'll tell you with the tax bill I
would be very surprised if I don't have
at least a few Democrats I have States
and I won by 30 points and more where
they have people running and frankly I
think and I get the impression that they
very much like the ideas of this tax
plan we'll be submitting on the
twenty-fifth detail everything were
busted most people know about the plan
in terms of the details but will
actually be opening up the week of the
25th and I think it's going to be
something that's going to be very
successful and I do believe well this is
not a plan for the rich this is a plan
for the middle class and this is a plan
for jobs and this is a plan to bring
four trillion dollars back into the
United States that people have wanted to
do for years both Democrat and
Republican for years they've wanted to
bring that money back into the United
States this is a plan to bring it could
be more than portrait and frankly nobody
really knows what the number is they've
been saying for years at Stewart 1/2
trillion but that was before years I've
been hearing that so obviously as much I
think it's anywhere between four and
five trillion dollars 33 more than that
we'll be bringing that back into the
United States I will have tremendous
Democrat support and Republican support
to them
it will be revenue-neutral when you add
growth because we're going to have
magnificent growth if you look at GDP
for the last quarter was 3% everybody
was shocked to see that I think we would
have had I'm not going to use numbers
but I think we would have had
substantially more than that for the
next quarter in GDP the problem is we
just got hit with two massive hurricanes
the likes of which we essentially
haven't seen before so that will have a
little bit of an impact and maybe more
than a little bit of an effect but we
have we have GDP if you raise if you go
up one point in GDP it takes care of
many sins if you go up two points it
takes care of everything and I think
we're going to rock it in terms of GDP
and don't forget I've been saying for a
long time that GDP is going to be higher
than you thought when GDP it when it hit
3% this last quarter people including
many of the people here we're very very
surprised because they thought it would
be about 1.7 or 1.8 a lot of it has to
do with all of the regulations I've cut
when people can actually now go out and
build and farm and do all the things
they want to do at the same time being
environmentally friendly and regulation
traveling so so I just want to say
including growth because it's a very
fair question a good question
if you want to win growth because we're
going to go like a rocket ship we're
going to more than make up the
difference
we've had bigger storms in this and if
you go back into the 1930s and the 1940s
and you take a look we've had storms
over the years that have been bigger
than this if you go back into the teens
you'll see storms that were as big or
bigger so we did have to you know
horrific storms epic storms but if you
go back into the 30s and 40s and you go
back into the teens you'll see some
storms that were very similar and even
you want to keep a Sherman gentleman I
do respect your man yelling a lot I like
it and I respect her but we haven't made
that decision yet
I didn't think this the country is doing
well we got hurt by the two hurricanes
but the country is doing very well miss
Akbar consider new high as you see jobs
are at a 17-year low unemployment is
that the highest number it's ever been
if you look at the unemployment is low
and the employment in the country is
just about at the highest point that's
ever been we're doing well and very
importantly just to finish companies are
starting to move back into our country
expansion of oil firms and plants
expansion of different things even
Foxconn I'm looking at you your iPhone
is made by you-know-who box table and
box gods will be into the country for
the first time Apple is going to be
building massive glass there's a big
reason for that and the reason happens
to be Trump have a good time everyone
fighting
it looks like the blocks bigger
- what was a bomb that exploded
I've been two or three on axis big it
looks like they might be making
preparations front under blast then
reaching up to shake it bake where are
you down
we have a very good relationship with
China and with the president China we
are working on different things I can't
tell you obviously want to work it on
but believe me the people of this
country will be very very safe
I think that a lot of effort is going to
be put into this we're looking at what's
going on having as we speak we are
literally looking at it right now and
you will be seeing I'll probably be
visiting I was invited by the president
we'll probably all be going over as a
group in sometime in November and we'll
be doing Japan South Korea possibly
Vietnam with the conference he invited
us we're going to see Higginson Korea it
looks like right now definite we've been
invited by the Philippines they want us
to go Vietnam to the company back so
what we'll possibly do in fact it'll be
a busy it'll be a busy ten days and keep
you guys busy and back in time for
Thanksgiving I hope so
I don't know